what's up elimination at seven this is a
special unique video that I'm making or
Charlie from charisma on command charlie
is a friend of mine I met in fact
climber cons he has an awesome challenge
teaching people how to be charismatic
I'm a huge fan of his channel I've
checked out every video that it put up
at least the recent ones and we went to
an escape room in that in L a bunch of
places so you see the fun undo it as
well and he recently crossed I'm really
subscribers on his channel I wanted to
make a thank you video to recognize him
and connected with some of his superfans
who had a personal message for him as
well hey Charlie Antonio here
congratulations a million subscribers
you you are fast man you worked hard you
have earned every single subscriber and
I congratulate you you've got a lot in
front of you so much potential so many
places that you're going to go in this
world and I am happy that I got to meet
you a clamor con I'm privileged that I
can call you my friend and I'm just
excited to see where you're going to
take things
congratulations charlie wishing you the
best Charlie not only do you share
knowledge with people but you're
actively teaching people to be honest
better themselves and in turn help
others congratulations on 1 million you
have damn well deserved it
congratulations on 1 million subscribers
charlie I remember watching one of your
videos way back in the day and I thought
to myself this guy is going to make it
big he's going to be one of the big
shots because he felt so much to offer
and you do you really did it well done
charisma on command has changed my life
it's given me the power to go after my
dreams it's given me insight into Who I
am and has helped me reach my goals like
no one else has I just want to thank you
for everything you've done for me your
videos has changed my life has changed
the way that I think about myself and
how I treat other people it's given me
the the energy and the desire to go
after my own dreams and to
to try and help other people with what
they're struggling through charisma on
command was the perfect title for your
channel because really you just ooze
charisma you are just the most
charismatic person I watch on YouTube
congratulations on reaching 1 million
subscribers I really hope and I'm pretty
sure you will reach another few million
more what you're doing is an amazing
thing so please keep it up never give up
never think to yourself that you're not
good enough because you've proven to
yourself into everyone who's watching
then you are good enough you're more
than good enough you're one of the best
you're one of the big ones so thank you
thank you very much for what you're
doing without you I wouldn't have found
the courage to start my own business
without you I wouldn't have had the
courage to go after my own dreams I
wouldn't have started my own YouTube
channel only big thumbs up from million
subscribers I hope to get a million more
in our time and probably well given the
fiber to your YouTube channel is so
unique helping strangers like me dealing
with their daily problems so thank you
thank you thank you Charlie 1 million
subscribers man that is fantastic
out of everyone on YouTube you really
deserve it like I've seen your stuff
since kickoff Academy the coffee you've
been putting out it's just novel unique
it gets better every time and I'm really
excited to see your future stuff I hope
to meet you one day if I go to Brazil
for Carnivale
I meant take care correspond command 1
million subscribers congratulations
hi Charlie I wanted to say that you not
only change lives of your subscribers
but you changed you to you and that's
great thank you so much for what do you
do and hyper Russia yes hey Charlie hey
Z here I want to congratulate you
charisma on command and reaching one
drivers and I just got to say I love
what you do find the best people with
all the best trades and you try to keep
us all doing our best you know you want
everybody to be positive and focused you
can't help but love it
I'm looking for it you have all the coal
to keep all of our inspirational players
burning for a long time he's my friend I
love you what's up Charlie this is Wes
and I want to give you a huge
congratulations on crossing 1 million
subscribers that is an absolutely
amazing milestone to reach and you
deserve every single last one of your
subs I've been a big fan of yours for
the past few years and you've helped me
develop my social skills in too many
ways to count and I just want to say
that I really appreciate all the time
work and effort that you put into making
your vids and I look forward to seeing
many more amazing videos from you in the
future
hey Charlie my name is cliff I just want
to say congratulation on 1 million
subscribers all your videos are great
and they're very helpful and I love them
all I love the breakdown celebrity
breakdown they're the best so yeah I
keep doing great in the future and I
wish you the best of luck haha hey
you're Charlie congratulations on
reaching 1 million subscribers it's been
such a pleasure to see your channel grow
and to see all of your hard work come up
to this milestone
thank you for instilling the confidence
in me that helps me spread messages to
the hundreds of thousands of young
people around the world and not only me
but others in your audience to interact
with hundreds of thousands of other
people in their lives your work is not
only having an impact on us but it's
having an impact on the world
hey Charlie huge congrats on smashing a
million subscribers I think that I'm not
alone in saying you've helped out so
many people just like me become better
versions of ourselves I've been watching
each and every single one of your videos
putting all of your advice into practice
since day one and I have to say that
things have just kept getting better I'm
sure you're going to keep on helping
people as we go on and let's go and
smash that next two million subscriber
five million ten million subscriber
milestones
I know you can do it keep it up mate
you've been also thank you
hey charisma on command I just want to
say congratulations on a million
subscribers your channel has helped me
out a lot there was one time that was
kind of embarrassing when I was in class
and your video how to text a girl popped
up with my subscriptions and a friend
made fun of me you thought that I was
searching up how to text a girl and it
was pretty embarrassing but other than
that your channel is great so keep up
the great work
so charlie congratulations again you've
obviously had a huge impact on a lot of
people you might be wondering who is
this guy and why is he here as well this
is Alex who helps run China dance salsa
and he's been on the channel two times
he is also a super fan and had a special
message for you as well Matt honestly I
love what you do especially Kevin Hart
I'm in a huge fan of him I follow them
on Instagram snapchat and your breakdown
of how he gets attention from his
audience making sure that he doesn't
crack jokes and so everyone's paying
attention I use that in my classes when
I keep salsa I use that to train my
assistants it's an awesome piece of
advice I'm always looking forward to the
new things are coming out your channel
especially the breakdowns I love those
breakdowns it's I don't know how you do
it but I why'd you keep doing it and do
more of it because I absorb it like a
sponge though thank you Miss awesome
congratulatory guys watching if you
don't know krismo command we'll link it
up in the description go check it out
it's a great channel to watch and if
there's somebody who recently reached a
milestone that you want to recognize
give them a shout out
spend a few minutes make a video write
them a note send them an email just send
a little bit extra love and say thank
you needs a little bit more of that as
well okay guys again for watching I
believe in you hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love guys see see
that's pretty good